Odell said I’m a murderer?
Haha, well that’s just our relationship, you know?
I mean, it’s not like
you can draft a QB over Saquon!
Yeah, I think they probably should have
Look, I love the fans
I would never harm a fan
But do I think they protect Eli?
YEAH, WELL HOW MANY RINGS HAS ODELL GIVEN US?
Eli won two Super Bowls against us
So now they are stuck with him forever
Rumors are, there’s tension
Eli, can you pass more to your best receiver?
No. We must only checkdown.
No comment! No comment!
But yes, I am loving this
BEN, GET OVER HERE
YOU WON’T BELIEVE WHAT GRUDEN DID NOW
Yeah, we don’t even need to be good
to win this division anymore
Look, I barely killed the Giants!
I’m not capable!
Coach, I’m here to bail you out again
OK, sorry, I have to have my family
yell at the Maras
Goodbye
What the hell did I do?
Ruined the Giants, of course